-Our first guest tonight i
a very funny comedian you know
from his work on
"Saturday Night Live"
and films like "Sisters"
and "The Secret Life of Pets."
He stars in the new show
"Mr. Mayor,"
which airs Thursday nights
here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Hey, Jayden, I found
the mayor's little bus speec
real original.
-It actually wasn't.
To save time, I just took
his last speech
and changed "algae bloom"
to "bus passengers."
-I was being sarcastic.
-Well, you're great at it.
-Yeah, Jayden, Twitter
has started to notice
that we're recycling speeches.
-Small businesses are
the lifeblood of this city
Reasonably priced produce is
The passing of Archbishop
Sheehan is the lifeblood -
You're killing me.
Yeah, the comms department may
be stretched a little thin
-Why, thank you.
-Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Bobby Moynihan.
How are you, Bobby?
Bobby? Oh, no.
Oh, no, Fred got to Bobby,
you guys.
-My Fred bit.
-How are you, my friend?
-Good. How are you, sir?
-I'm good.
So, you're actually in a trailer
right now.
You guys are shooting?
-I'm in a trailer.
I just moved in.
It's very nice.
Yeah, no, we're shooting
episode nine right now.
-Episode nine.
And I think when you think o
how long between a pilot
and then when you actually shoot
the second episode,
that's a fairly long time.
But then you guys had it
stretched out even longer
because of the pandemic.
How long have you been working
on Season 1 of this show?
-We may have beaten
some sort of television record
We started shooting this
I think last year.
We were on episode four
when the lockdown happened
So we've been shooting
for a while.
And then we all became
very good friends over Zoo
and then came back
and started shooting.
And it felt like a reunion for
a show that hasn't aired yet
-And from that clip, I mean,
there's some real heavy hitter
in there, Bobby.
Holly Hunter and Ted Danson.
How's that been so far?
-It's the greatest.
Ted Danson might be
the nicest human in the world.
And watching Holly Hunter
do anything is the best.
I'm in love with her.
She's this big and I want to
carry her around on my shoulder.
[ Laughter ]
-How is sitcom life
versus "SNL"?
You always had such a good eye
for sort of everyday weirdoe
that you would see
and then use as inspiration.
Is it different now that
you're just playing one man?
-Yes. We know our own, Seth.
Yes.
I play Jayden Kwapis in this
I think he's enough of a weird
for all of my "SNL" needs
of playing lots of weirdoes.
I'm very happy.
-Jayden Kwapis
is a fantastic name.
-Not so bad.
-A Carlock and Tina Fey --
A Robert Carlock
and Tina Fey special,
which leads to a great joke in
the pilot about the name Jayden.
But, Bobby,
I don't need to tell you
you've long been a lover o
crazy names for characters
-I love crazy names.
I'm no James Anderson.
James Anderson makes up
the best names in the world,
but I am a fan of insane names
yes.
-These are just some character
you played on "SNL."
We collected a li-- Riblet
-Correct.
-You played Ass Dan
and his identical twin brother
Do you remember
Ass Dan's twin brother?
-Butt Dave.
Yeah, it was supposed to b
Jeff Bridges,
but it wasn't. It was me.
[ Laughter ]
-You played Slappy Pappy
and Janet Peckenpaw.
You played Nif.
What was Nif short for?
-Kennif.
-[ Laughs ]
-That was a Neil Casey original.
Kennif is short -- Yeah, Nif
was short for Kennif.
-Kirby J. Buttercream,
Trash Yard Mutt.
You played a character
named Danny Cartoons?
-Danny Cartoons. I think
that may have gotten cut.
But, yes, I did.
-What was Danny Cartoons
known from?
-In the Larry David sketch
about the doughnut,
about when he popped out
and he had the doughnut.
I don't remember.
[ Laughter ]
About a doughnut.
-And then Bitch Fantastic
was a character.
-Bitch Fantastic was a nam
that I wrote on a Post-It Note
months before I got "SNL."
And I said, "Someday I want to
use this on the show,"
and I think I got it
on in my eighth year.
[ Laughter ]
-Sometimes the best --
You needed America
to be ready for it.
-Correct.
I'm still not sure they are.
-What about Toothpick
and Skippy?
Were you Skippy
or were you Toothpick?
-I was Skippy.
I was a man who enjoyed to eat
Skippy peanut butter
all the time.
And Jay was just a silent ma
was a toothpick in his mouth
And we were two shy men
who worked in an office
who always wanted to be
asked to hang out,
but when they got
they were too afraid
to hang out.
It was insane.
-And how did the sketch go
during dress?
-As you would think,
it went fine.
I think Will Ferrell
was the host.
He was a little tired, and i
was the one sketch where, like
we kind of felt that it migh
not go 'cause it was insane.
Both Skippy and Peanut die
at the end of the sketch.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Will Ferrell, as he was
leaving the stage, was, like
"Oh, that was great.
We're not gonna do that one.
[ Laughter ]
I felt very thankful for him
to know before the show started,
and I was, like, "Yeah,
that one's not happening."
-He had good instincts.
We'll be right back with
more from Bobby Moynihan.